Birena Gupta: After selling my latest startups
My husband and I decided to travel around the world
And during our travels
We came up with the idea of ​​creating Hooked
This is a picture of a place in Costa Rica where I love writing
And inspired new ideas
The Hooked application is intended to tell short stories
In the form of chats
Sarah Abdullah: I love writing
I grew up in love reading Arabic literature
This has prompted me to share my experiences with my children
I did not find a way to communicate with them better than the language they speak
So I decided to create Makooky World
After I had been thinking for years
Makooky World is an interactive application featuring stories, songs and games in Arabic
Kim Tae Neller: represents the kiwi symbol voltage
And perseverance to reach the highest goals
Zen Koi shows a small fish trip from Koi fish
Until it becomes a dragon
What fish do you play?
SPEAKER 4: I play with Yellow Coke
Maria Martina: I learned from my mother and my sisters
That no matter how you face challenges
I have to learn how to rise after a failure
And try again
Their advice has had a great impact on my work
Sarah Abdullah: It was not an easy start
Because this area was completely new to me
But it was worth the effort
I had no investments
That means I needed to invest my time and money
And start a very small team
Maria Martina: At first we had no experience in the field of games
It was our specialty to produce films, cartoons and story books
Each of us has a different background
We have learned a lot from our work elsewhere
But we were struggling to make our own games
And to provide stories of our authorship
It was hard to get support
Kim Tai Neller: The establishment of Zen Koi was a daunting trip for us
But we decided to continue
Knowing that we did not have enough money for it
The launch of Hooked has been a scary step
There were many doubts
My biggest fear was that the project would stop there
Maria Martina: After years of challenge and learning
Finally, we achieved impressive results
By working on our own game Realms of the Void
It is a multi-role strategy game
Kim Tai Neller: After attracting the first 20 installation
We felt comfortable and happy too
Because the game became accessible to everyone
Zen Koi now has a total of nine million installs
Birena Gupta: We continued to work, after a year of trials and tests
We were able to translate the application into seven different languages
We launched it around the world until Hooked achieved first place
In more than 25 countries
We've reached more than 13.5 million installs on Android
Sara Abdullah: What drives me to advance every morning
Is the ability to create something new
I have always dreamed of doing it
Kim Tai Neller: The success of Zen Koi is back to luck
Many patience, perseverance and support from family and friends
Sara Abdullah: I would like to teach my daughters an important message
That they can accomplish the impossible if they want
I have a responsibility as a mother
To prove them through the realization of my dreams
That they can achieve their dreams as well
Maria Martina: I'm lucky with this wonderful team
And whatever the days have hidden
We will continue our efforts to achieve what we want
Birena Gupta: When creating a new product you love
And is looking to launch it in the market
This is what keeps you working
And so leave your mark in the world